it's wonderful to see all three of you i
just finished last night the last
episode and it's absolutely epic
i can't season 4 is probably the best
season i've seen so congratulations to
all of you have you kind of soaked in
the success of this show the obsession
people have with it
peyton
oh my gosh i don't think i'll ever soak
it in
no i really don't i mean
i came on later than everybody else but
um i i think because it happened during
the pandemic of the show into netflix
and a lot of it has just been online and
it's kind of surreal when someone comes
up in person and and talks about the
show it's it's mind-blowing
it's pretty crazy and then you have
andrew garfield like saying he's one of
the biggest fans and you guys make a
video for him and he's like this is the
best thing in my life but it like
reaction have you seen his video the way
he reacts to it
mary oh oh yeah i'm sorry i was just a
little speechless for a second uh yeah
and i was like that was lit i i
legitimized open mouth like i was like
we got this so we got this email right
and it was like hey like andrew
garfield's a fan and like tick tick
boom's coming out like we'd love to like
do a video for him like thanks for you
know watching cobra guy and i was like
ha ha like no freaking way like this is
one of those things where somebody like
asked him like what do you watch and
he's like i don't know i guess don't
work and then i watched the video saying
oh he's like kind of legitimately a fan
i was like oh my god i got so excited i
was so nervous filming the video and
then seeing his reaction to it i got
like i got so emotional i was so i'm
fangirled i thank girl heart it's so
great i mean now that you're shooting
season five he needs to be part of it
right
uh yeah he exists in the universe in my
mind
[Laughter]
something
yeah it's great there's so many people
who love this show and tanner i was
watching your social media on instagram
one of your videos it looks like you
guys really do train in karate and you
did like a i think it was like a 5 40
turn kick but i don't even know what
it's called uh are you kidding me so are
you in love with the style of karate
actually yeah yeah it's become one of
those things where
um we do we train constantly uh
almost every day um and it's been one of
those things where when you
even when the season ends and you don't
you're maybe moving on to other things
and trying to do other other work you
you really do at least for me you miss
it you're like why can't i need to i
need to get back into this i need to
start doing this i need to be stretching
i need to be working and sweating and
trying to learn new things so it's
definitely one of those things where you
just i i love it now i love that and
what would you say of your three
characters most
that represents the most about cobra kai
it's it's its values which of your three
characters
i think tory is the classic cobra kai
story of of
not in a negative way but really seeing
the story behind a bully like gray
behind
somebody that from the outside you would
see is as coarse and rough and the way
that we saw you know johnny in in the
80s uh this you know classic bad boy
bully type and then getting to like
really understand the why and the how
and and and what could bring somebody to
to become that kind of person i think
tory's a great representation and and
because it's a series and because we're
in 2021 we get to dive more into that
and like actually understand you know
the why and the how instead of just
making presumptuous decisions
that's a really good really good answer
because it's interesting because season
four does focus on
right off the top i don't want to spoil
it but this kid was getting bullied and
the importance of how to deal with it
and tanner your character does such a
great job in terms of helping him
through it um you guys also celebrate
60th birthday of ralph you guys all got
together is this like a family i guess
it's a family show you guys really do
get along
yeah
i i guess i can kind of show this right
now but that's my phone background oh
is that everybody's here
we did that at peyton's house a couple
weeks ago but uh but yeah i know this
has been i feel like the first
experience i've had in my career were
like i mean i've worked with some
wonderful people and i'm so appreciative
where i've really gotten to spend ton of
time with people to build these bonds
and these long lasting uh inside jokes
that we have it's it's been really cool
you